الجميله سوريا ساحه بلختبر للمسيرات لدول
ومجموعه مسلحه متنوعه تقرير لمنظمه باكثر
هولنديه لبناء السلام ذكر ان كل من
الولايات المتحده وروسيا وايران واسرائيل
وتركيا فضلا عن قوه النظام السوري استخدم
39 نوعا مختلفا من المسرات خلال النزاع
المستمر منذ العام 2001 10 المنظمه وفي
تقريرها اعتبرت ان سوريا شكلت مختبرا سمح
للدول والمجموعات المسلحه غير الحكوميه
باختبار انواع جديده من المسيرات بل
مكنتها من دراستكيه تحسين استخدامها من
خلال التكتيكات والاستراتيجيه العسكريه
فخلال العقد الاخير اظهرت الطائره المسيره
المطوره في الاجواء السوريه كيفيه مرور
الجهات العسكريه المتعدده بمرحله تعلم
وكيف عززت من معرفتها من ناحيه التصميم
والانتاج
الطائره المسيره المتفجره الايرانيه
والروسيه والامريكيه اضحى تستخدم على نطاق
واسع في الحرب باوكرانيا
التقرير اورد ايضا ان المسيارات التركيه
تشنت اكثر من 60 غارتا ضد مناطق سيطره
المقاتلين الاكراد شماليه سوريا بين يناير
وسبتمبر من العمل الجاري هذه المسيره
تستعملها ايضا النظام السوري كما قدمتها
ايران للمليشيات المسلحه التابعه لها في
المنطقه كالفصائل العراقيه حزب الله
اللبناني سوريا وفق التقرير مختبر ومصدر
للمسيرات التي تنشر الخراب شرقا وغربا
بلال الوجداني العربيه